I'm Erika Penck.
I'm your Unreal Authorized Instructor for today,
and we're doing retargeting in crowds.
And you guys are in for a treat.
So I want to give a big thanks to Alex Paschel,
who created the content for this course.
And here's what we're going over today.
So retargeting is what allows you to download animations
from the Marketplace or Mixamo and apply it to your character
or apply it to your metahuman, for example.
We'll cover how to create and control blend spaces,
which are useful for transitioning
between animations in games.
We'll even build off of our retargeting exercise
to complete the navigation in crowds portion.
And that will allow you to potentially fill out
a scene of pedestrians walking along a sidewalk
that you don't want to hand anime.
And today, all you need to do
is open up a third-person template project,
turn on the Take Recorder plugin,
and then you're ready to follow along.